do you believe in the power of
conversation since you have contacts
with Vladimir zielinski and Vladimir
Putin just lead her sitting in a room
And discussing how the end of War can be
brought about
I think it's a combination of that but I
think it's the question of interest and
uh and whether you have to get both
sides
to a point where they
think that that conversation would lead
to something useful I don't think
they're there right now what part of of
this is just basic human ego
stubbornness all of this between leaders
which is why I bring up the power of
conversation of sitting in a room
realizing we're human beings and then
there's a history that connects Ukraine
and Russia yeah I don't think they're in
a position to enter a room right now
realistically I mean you can posit that
it would be good if that could happen
but entering the room is sometimes more
complicated than what happens in the
room and there's a lot of you know
pre-negotiation on the negotiation then
you negotiate endlessly on the
negotiation they're not even there